you know what I would say that I was
that I was laughing at what the new Elon
Musk Joe Rogan podcast Oh bro I didn't
dude I didn't really watch the first one
I saw the memes but I didn't I never
actually watched anything I watched like
a 10 minute clip I think of him talking
about I forget you know something like
clickbait worthy where I was like oh I
wonder what his opinion on that is and I
clicked it yeah in Washington it was it
was fine
like the chemistry seemed kind of kind
of natural but like man this new one it
is [ __ ] awkward dude it is so
uncomfortable
dude the the silence he takes before
answering this is that's the biggest
problem it's he's like you were you're
talking about with it with the the kid
you were just streaming with I feel like
he's so you know in the spotlight
everything says people are gonna break
down yeah and you know people you know
he's a billionaire so that automatically
makes him this I don't know like villain
almost in most people's eyes and so he
he is so careful about what he says that
just makes the conversations so hard to
listen to yeah because he can't just
freely yeah he caters behaves to be like
[ __ ] I like he talks for a second
about like why he thinks it's wrong that
billionaires are villainized and I'm Liz
I'm like oh we tread carefully here and
you can tell he just wants to go like
just cut the [ __ ] man
look at all the [ __ ] I [ __ ] done okay
yeah I'm bringing us two goddamn Mars
I'm saving this [ __ ] race and you're
gonna like you're gonna give me just
grabs the camera he's like listen here
[ __ ] yeah real close up on the
mic Liz you listen to me I gave you the
Model X huh who's giving you the Model X
no one give me credit where my credit is
due
yeah bro hehe like he can't even he
doesn't even have the luxury of when
someone goes what's neuro-link all about
he goes ask to some [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
working on yeah like he he can't even
sidestep he has to explain everything he
does which all the time which is funny
because he tweeted
tweets that he did the other day where
he's like the stock price is too high
yes the stock and then he's like also
I'm selling all my possessions like
he'll come on these weird Twitter rants
but then but then Joe's like so what's
this I thought you want to sell all your
possessions and he's like yeah and I was
like why he's like I don't know I think
of possessions tie you down just like
okay so dude what do you mean like do
you have all these houses and you're
just gonna get rid of them he's like
yeah he said what do you do rent just
rent a place he's like yep probably you
nailed that we did you listen you listen
until I could hear it is that why you're
growing it out and you're trying to
become disheveled because you're trying
to you're prepping for the Elon biopic
that you're emulating him yeah yeah I'm
trying to get casted for mhm
yep I've started I've started to ask
people to refer to me as just bio 0-5
mmm
you mean Kyle yeah bro he he made that
you made that [ __ ] 64 character
barcode to say Kyle wait no it's not
pronounced Kyle yes it is it's not you
ready you ready for the screenshot look
at the screenshot right here
wait hold on no no wait wait oh god did
someone like made this thing it was a
meme yeah yeah yeah it pronounced it was
pronounced Kyle dude I was I fell for it
I [ __ ] fell for it I mean it got me
[ __ ] yeah
X is the Greek letter for you no Kai
pronounced ki and ash is pronounced AI
and then a a 12 12th letter of the
alphabet L Rose third grade I was about
to say I'm like did he just [ __ ] do
all that too
say Kai all right XE r12 it's your turn
to read he's like you mean Kyle it's
pronounced mikail
it's pronounced Kyle [ __ ] oh my god
I'm so sorry
mr. Feeny mr. musk those memes were so
[ __ ] there's stupid as hell would
they had me crying one of them was it
was like you know X ash 12 teacher on
the first day trying to call it out is
just like a [ __ ] woman's face like
[Laughter]
hey bro so the best part of this whole
exchange is once I know so Grimes went
on Twitter and explained the name and
the last of it is a 12 precursor to the
SR 17 our favorite aircraft first of all
what couple has a favorite aircraft
that's the richest thing ever that's our
favorite aircraft [ __ ] you subtle flecks
oh that one has the best bathrooms yeah
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] kid that's gonna
be he's in a friend group where'd you
get the end of your bar code name oh
it's my parents favorite jet what is
that what is that plane that was in an
army plane yeah well so so it says no
weapons no defenses just speed great in
battle but nonviolent and then elan
replies sr-71 but yes auch angel 12 wait
so this is Grimes tweeting and he's
replying to it
yeah and he's correcting her because she
said the a12 is the precursor to those
babies Aventine and he goes it's not our
favorite aircraft it's mine it's mine
yeah I saw 17 one but yes the you know
what the funniest thing is you all must
have like five other kids look up their
name yeah they're probably like Alan and
just like normal I should even
acknowledge those kids yeah Nevada
Damien Griffin Xavier Saxon kaizen Saxon
all right so yeah maybe they are maybe
they do kind of have weird
then Xavier yeah I mean Xavier is not
really that weird of a name though yeah
I guess yeah yeah I guess at this point
I mean bro in history we have the weird
names in history they had all the you
know like Greek names are crazy yeah
that's true
you know like pair of titties could be a
pair of titty Cleese could be Hera
testiclees
yeah a pair of testicles it even just
testiclees nibblies yeah testiclees
nipples blue King wants you in the in
the garden testicle laser would it be
appeared to me that you have been
fondling with nipply Singlish I cry
shake fondle my knee please what's the
last one's name um ex a sh a 12o that's
the one I can't read at a 12 on you know
I'm sorry it's I can try you think
they're gonna be like bitter like a
[ __ ] ex ash is coming over again yeah
no totally ex ass shows up just like
spiky choker [ __ ] you know like some
41 golf what if he's just hyper what if
he's just hyper self-aware and hates the
[ __ ] out of it what if he renames
himself in school he's like just just
call me Dan mm-hmm and then people tease
him what's up ex act that's not even a
name you can like you can't even make
fun of it you can't bully it it's too
weird it doesn't have like a ringy thing
to it what's up ex okay you look stupid
just saying it like that so the most
anyone is gonna say is you know you know
oh look it's my Apple support ticket or
you know [ __ ] you know everyone's
made the strong password joke this is
the strongest you know all that [ __ ] oh
oh sick it's my [ __ ] Delta
confirmation number yeah until a [ __ ]
rocket launcher comes out of his [ __ ]
mouth and he just blows up your whole
family dude I gotta say Saxon mosque is
a pretty strong name that's a dope ass
porn saxon mosque it sounds like a like
a cologne doesn't it
you